[Musique]
aujourd'hui le suicide d'un chômeur ne
fait plus la une
car s'il reste rare heureusement il n'a
plus rien d'exceptionnel en 6 mois 25
chômeurs au moins se sont donné la mort
le corps nu que nous recevons ici au
syndicat des chômeurs à clichy dans les
hauts-de-seine est belle en effet une
situation souvent critique et parfois
dramatiques
voici quelques lettres que nous avons
reçu ces jours ci chez 55 ans je ne
trouve pas de travail il me reste plus
qu en finir avec la vie
certes l'absence de travail n'est pas
toujours la seule raison de ces gestes
désespérés mais souvent elle y contribue
pourquoi parce que le chômage peut dans
certains cas provoquer long terme des
symptômes des troubles d'ordre
psychologique ou psychiatrique bien
connue des médecins les mauvaises en
finir
[Musique]